through all the ground for a country
with this tax system okay now on you
Laura when you text we can just split to
the previous page okay now what sure
being asked if produces something like
this okay now I want to point out some
features to you off this number one this
graph is actually a bunch of graphs sewn
together right we have a name for this
is that's what the pain is in remember
we call this a piecewise graph because
tracker and it's several pieces okay
I hope that rings a bell my life these
wires piecemeal it's yeah tell me help
me understand what makes these pieces
different is that like this is statement
this amount and this one gets steeper
and this one gets steeper again why do
the different parts for the grammar have
different stiffnesses and by the way I'm
gonna stop saying sicknesses now because
it's a weird word and we have a better
word for it we call it gradient for the
grain increases what is that will return
back to this page that you were looking
at a second ago okay
the gradient represents how much are you
paying per dollar of income how much tax
you pay right now if you're paying 19
cents per dollar that means it's going
up at this amount right 13 cents per
dollar but as you transition to the next
tax bracket you're paying or so it will
be steeper and then we transition again
you get steeper another time okay so
when you come back to this graph each of
these represents each of these
represents a tax bracket okay so that's
the first thing I wanted to point out
the second thing I want to point out is
this graph doesn't start the origin you
can see where the origin is right in the
bottom left hand corner why doesn't it
start before
okay very good so what you've got here
is this tax-free income ha look at with
me can you tell me in this particular
country what the tax-free income is in
this country
so when I have a look at this I'm just
going to I'm just going to treat it as
if that's exactly on one of these green
lights even if it's not because I can't
read it any better you've got twenty
thousand dollars here right and then
there's one two three four five markings
to get you twenty thousand so how much
is each marking it's four thousand each
so that makes this four thousand eight
thousand twelve so please that just
really be the quotient right the first
twelve thousand dollars are tax-free and
then they start texting you at some
amount okay now they represent this
particular point where it switches right
they represent it and they say hey look
$4,200 they may try to give you more
details it's hard to read obviously and
accurately so add that up and that
mehleb it when you hit the next tack run
attacks back it
they say that's four thousand two
hundred dollars you have to pay now look
at you Matt for a second now this number
represents using forty thousand dollars
when you hit that forty thousand dollars
that's how much you have to take now no
it's not this is very very very taxing
country okay
now when you come here what's the
equivalent what's like one of those
points that we problem it actually is
two so the first thing that is in this
country it's not twelve thousand dollars
that you get first tax rate what is the
amount of you eight thousand so I
believe that here okay so I'm like okay
foods you retain we're all going for
this in a minute once I get rid of this
then you start going up now way do you
go up to have a look I know I'm gonna go
up to from eight thousand one to twenty
thousand dollars the graphs going up the
second
it's $20,000 I'm gonna have to write the
stems you have to help me when you are
earning $20,000 how much tax are you
paying can you use this to help me work
it out yeah how much how much the number
is this number but why is it that number
right this part down with me right for
an income of $20,000 sorry I'll just
squeeze it in over here okay the amount
of tax you pay is based on what it says
everything the right hand side right 19
cents per dollar in excess of 8,000 how
many dollars are you in excess of a
thousand its 12,000 right in other words
it's 20,000 take away 8,000 to it
there's the 12,000 and you'll multiply
that by how many cents of the dollar 19
so this is only dollars so I'm going to
stay in Dallas that's 0.198 agree that
now when you go ahead and hit equals on
your calculator unsurprisingly you
should get 2,000 turned to me and that's
what this number represents it
represents all the tax you paid in the
previous brackets and then you have to
pay more or depends how many there's no
ball what's this time we're going to
represent for the rest of you all the
tax you pay in these brackets and then
if you pay if you've been wanting that
you have to pay a higher rate so now
we're ready
join us up up the set of axes now I
reckon if I could squeeze dinner
okay so I'm going to do this I'm going
to try to as roughly as I can so that
you can fit it on GPL remember look at
your number see on your first eighteen
thousand eight thousand dollars rather
the tax-free okay sir from 0 up to
$8,000 where is the line representing
your tax from zero to eight thousand
more you draw the line but now he from
8001 to twenty thousand so I'm gonna go
up eight thousand I guess that would
make that 16 thousand so do you like
that this is gonna go up it's gonna go
up what's it going to go up to well
you've already with this outcome you at
twenty thousand
this is how would you go there exactly
then enough okay so let's plot that
somewhere on let's put um what you say
was easier to to zero now this is my tax
axis what's this my country very good
wake up
so from here there's my eight thousand
dollars tax-free and I'm gonna go up in
a straight line to my $20,000 point okay
that's how much I'm thirty these stiff
notice how much tax on paper I want is
there have a look what's the next
bracket I wanna look it's sixty good so
that's twenty so I need to go so there's
sixty okay now you don't have to do any
calculation
they've done it all for you if you learn
exactly six thousand come
second of all right do you see it let's
try and do this reasonably so next it's
about eight times high that's why I'm
number so low so if I go one two three
four five six seven
uh-huh eight okay because I put a scale
I've got to be consistent you guys have
got that paper so you can it's been in
my hand at $60,000 you're gonna go all
the way up until here how's that they're
fastened Big John
so there's sixty thousand and there is
my sixteen to eighteen sir
so you 80 I haven't left myself enough
space but this one last thing that they
see added to you right which is the next
tax bracket goes even steeper so it's
like okay shallow steep the next one
what my ass is gonna go so what you've
done is you've replicated this thing
here can you see it's got no above it it
just kind of keeps on going right
because after that it's like there's no
man it's low like then the tax bracket
ends and then you change again it's just
going to go on and on forever fourteen
times okay